hello everyone thank you for joining i
think this uh
third event of the spectator's
alternative conference
um and first off obviously uh the
spectator's hosting this general thing
conference but i wanted to start by
thanking our sponsor barclays for
sponsoring this panel
um the topic today out and into the
world can
britain reclaim free trade so as brexit
talks reach what could be the final
stage
um where that final stage leads to more
talks or
no tunnel we seem to be at a point where
no matter
what happens with the uk's talks with
the eu
clearly by the end of the year we are at
a crossroads for the uk's trade policy
uh we know that many trade agreements
have already been rolled over
we have had in the japan deal the first
uh deal the uk has struck which goes
further and beyond what we had under uh
the eu arrangement
and there's a hope in government that
there'll be plenty more to follow
and yet uh we still don't know when we
might hear about a uk us trade deal
there are questions about whether china
clearly one of the largest economies
is one that the uk will be prioritizing
or seeking to
do business with in that sense and then
we get back to the eu
so to discuss all these things and
ultimately both the
on an international level and also i
think the frictions back in the uk
does seem that we often pick up the
papers and hear about uh
tory different opinions too on what
should we prioritize in these free trade
deals
and i'm delighted to be joined by our
panel today that i'm just going to run
through
then i'm going to ask all the panel
members to give a two minute or so
address i've been told we'll be very
strict in that
um but we'll see we'll see how my time
counting goes
and and then we're going to have a
discussion and but i also want to get as
many audience questions in as possible
so if you do have something you want to
ask one of the panelists
um i think the way it is you write it in
the zoom chat and
technology will hopefully all be well
there and um i will get
through them all we have to finish on
the dot by 10 45 oh sorry 11 45
otherwise this conference would already
be over and i think
hopefully after much work the s behind
me is the right way great
okay so we're good to go so with that
i'd like to welcome our panel
um so we are joined today by james bin's
global head of trade and working capital
at barclays
uh mark littler wood director general of
the institute of economic affairs
i'm sure everyone has read uh many of
mark's pieces on uh
why a no deal brexit might not be so bad
and also what we should be looking for
on free trade and adam marshall director
general of the british chambers of
commerce
and last but by no means least uh liz
trust
secretary of state for international
trade um
so to kick things off i would normally
do ladies first but actually liz i think
i'm
gonna go to you last you get the final
word in a way that way
and so let's start by hearing from mark
okay great well katie thank you very
much i'm
this this is one area of the world where
i'm optimistic about um
thanks in part to the efforts already
made by
liz who's joined us today uh but i think
much done
much left to do i just want to make a
few points
which uh give rise to my optimism but
just a couple of warnings as well
firstly benefits of trade are about the
only thing that governments tend to
radically understate governments have a
tendency to promise that any
uh enterprise they're engaged with is
going to bring absolutely sensational
rates of return
whether that's hs2 or spending on
education or anything else
good evidence to suggest that we
understate the benefits
of freeing up trade uh i suspect that
the deal that we've stuck with
that we've struck with japan will be
enormously more beneficial than the
official forecasts
uh new zealand is the standout example
on this when when they
set their trade deals with um china
they thought it would be worth about 350
million
new zealand kiwi dollars a year in fact
it was 4.2 times that and that's because
trade has a dynamic uh
effect it's not just a question of
cheaper and higher quality products
coming into the market
uh it is a question of what you do with
those products
secondly we've got to be clear we're
playing multi-dimensional chess here
i think a problem with the previous
government was that we were playing
chess with the eu
not realizing that surrendering a pawn
or a rook on that chessboard
had implications for the deals that we
might make with japan or the usa
um the eu chessboard matters a lot but
it's not the only game in town and if we
put
all of our focus on that then uh
liz's job in trying to strike deals with
japan or america is made enormously
harder thirdly and katie
you uh you mentioned this
we've got to put our trade team in
charge of our regulatory rule book
in effect although tariffs matter it's
regulation that matters more
and if we're going to take a position
that there can be absolutely no change
to our banking standards our insurance
standards our animal welfare standards
our health and safety standards none
whatsoever
then we're sending our trade team uh
into uh negotiations
with both hands tied behind their back
this is a
challenge of trying to align or scrap
uh regulations to smooth trade and i am
concerned that there are voices on the
conservative benches who are
making our ability to strike deals
harder
um but ultimately we've got to we've got
to understand and i'm not going to go so
far as to correct you katie because i
think you're right that the end of this
year is a
crucial point that will set our
trajectory for our relationship with the
eu going forward
but we have to start looking at trade
and trade deals as an incremental
process not that we get to some single
unified deal with the eu
or america or japan and that's it it
needs to be reiterated year after year
after year after year
uh with regard to japan we should be
going back every year and trying to
improve that deal
um if we wherever we get to with the eu
whatever deal we struggle if there's no
deal that will not be the final word we
should be
continually returning to the table again
i think the kiwis have got this right
the european union and the mindset of
the uk
in general the media classes in
particular gets it wrong this is if
we're going to
write a text and that will stand for all
time no you've got to keep going back
and back and back
and the last point i'd make if i'm just
within my two minutes
this is an interesting area in which
game theory comes up against economics
i think a lot of economists would say
unilateral free trade is the way to go
just because other countries are
blocking up their ports doesn't mean you
need to block up your own ports
uh if the germans or the japanese or the
chinese want to
sell stuff cheaply we should buy it that
i think has good economic theory behind
it
but ignores the game theory that our
politicians such as liz need to
go through that if you go to the table
saying we're going to scrap all of our
tariffs on you come what may
your position of negotiation to
encourage them
to remove tariffs on us is limited so i
think that's an interesting
tension i think the economics the
economic textbooks would suggest just
declare unilateral free trade now
but if we want to actually get back to
our historical position of being the
greatest pioneers of free trade in the
world
then we need to actually use that
leverage to get others to embrace free
trade as well and that requires tough
negotiations
not merely economic theory great thank
you mark and now james do you want to
give us your opening remarks
thank you very much katie i'm delighted
to be taking part in today's panel and
thank you for the invite i'm really
looking forward to the discussion ahead
at barclays we've been supporting trade
for over 300 years for uk businesses
and today our focus on trade remains as
strong as ever
trade is absolutely part of our dna
we've got specialist
trade teams across the uk and indeed
across the globe
we have a range of comprehensive trade
solutions aimed at small
medium and large size businesses there's
a lot going on at the moment
there's brexit there's coven 19 there's
u.s china trade tensions
to name but a few and for uk businesses
that means volatility
complexity and uncertainty we see
trade solutions and trade support as
being absolutely
vital to helping those uk businesses
navigate the current environment that
we're
we're working in so that they can not
only minimize
risk and uncertainty but also seize new
opportunities
and in that regard it was fantastic to
see the new
uh us sorry uk uh japan trade deal being
announced recently and i congratulate
the secretary of state for international
trade in that regard
we're working very closely with
organizations like uk export finance the
department of international trade
other organizations like the institute
of exporters
we and i feel those organizations those
departments
remain absolutely critical to helping us
all navigate through these these waters
that we currently
stand in or swimming
and we're working very very closely with
ucaf
and department of international trade in
particular to help uk businesses
once again i'm delighted to be taking
part in the panel today
and i'm really looking forward to the
debate ahead thank you
brilliant thank you and now let's go
over to adam
katie thanks very much and good morning
everyone
i suppose i'm here today representing
business communities around the uk
and some of their point of view on what
the concept
of free trade means uh both in terms of
their current
and future operations uh interestingly
and perhaps a bit provocatively i'd say
that from the point of view
of business the phrase that we're using
to describe today's seminar
reclaim free trade is a bit of a strange
turn of phrase
because businesses never actually felt
they lost it in the first place
governments may have lost uh some of
their zest
for free trade but i don't think
businesses ever have and it's important
to remember that
distinction um so the better question i
think we need to answer is whether
our politicians and our leadership
embrace
what a free trading environment really
means
and avoid a retreat into a bit of a
narrow or more protectionist view
of our economic future we've seen that
happen in other places around the world
um thankfully here in the uk we have not
and i know that the secretary of state
when she comes up to speak will
probably very firmly reject that sort of
protectionist view of the world
but invariably the sense in business
communities is that would of course make
us
significantly poorer over the long term
going back to mark's point about the
benefits that trade can have
uh just three very quick points of
introduction from me
the first is to always remember that
businesses
not countries do trade deals and they
need active championing and they need
active support from governments and from
financial institutions
in order to close them trade agreements
between
countries such as those the secretary of
state is working so hard to achieve
make those business-to-business deals
easier but they are not the end
in their own right the business is
actually doing the trading and doing the
deals between themselves that is the
goal we are all seeking to achieve
i think the second point is that
businesses are of course pragmatic
and many will go where the demand is
so if they notice that a market is
opening up post coronavirus or that the
speed of the recovery in that market is
greater
many businesses will reorientate their
attention relatively quickly
and of course they will do the same when
there are favorable conditions from a
free trade agreement and then i suppose
finally
on those trade agreements themselves the
things that the secretary of state many
of her cabinet colleagues are working so
hard
on there is a prioritization from the
established business community
in the uk as to when they need to be
achieved and what needs to be achieved
the top priority still coming up from
the grassroots is
to get that free trade agreement with
the european union over the coming weeks
seen as extremely important
to do by many of those who are
established in business
the second is to continue the work that
the secretary of state and her
predecessor were doing on continuity
agreements around the world
we too very much applaud the japan deal
it can only work to its best extent when
we combine it together with a good
european deal and with others around the
world because of things like rules of
origin etc
um and then finally of course businesses
are hugely interested in what can be
achieved with the us
with australia with new zealand with
other markets all across the world for
so many reasons
but i suppose the message still is let's
try to get an eu deal done because
that will be a baseline for many others
and help
many others in future great now
liz
well thanks thanks very much and in
answer to the question
can britain reclaim free trade
yes we absolutely can and i think we're
in a superb position to do that
no other country has been in a position
of being able to simultaneously
negotiate so many new trade agreements
at the same time
we're the sixth largest economy in the
world we're a very very valuable
consumer market and what i'm seeing
is lots of countries want to
come to the table to talk trade with the
uk
uh we've got a strong pipeline of
others who want to be involved in
negotiations
and i think we're in a real position to
make the uk
the center of a network of free trade
agree
deals a a hub if you like and
the crucial components of that first of
all accession to the trans-pacific
partnership
of which securing the japan deal is a
crucial stepping stone but that's why
also australia and new zealand will be
very important as well the likes of
canada and mexico
but also the deal with the us uh on
which we're making
significant progress we've just been
exchanging market access offers in terms
of the tariffs
so we're getting into a deep level of
negotiation with the us
and i think this is important
economically for britain
you know we've very much been eu facing
and of course the eu trade deal is
important
but there's an opportunity for us to
reach out more widely
around the world and champion britain's
key strengths in areas like financial
services data and digital
small and medium-sized enterprises food
and drink
and also hitch ourselves to the fastest
growing areas of the world
we've got to not just look at the status
quo of where trade is now but also where
trade will be in the future
and how can the uk benefit that
but more broadly than just the economic
benefits
there are the geostrategic benefits of
trade
and we've got an opportunity to work
with like-minded partners to shape the
future rules of trade
the wto's rule book hasn't been changed
significantly since 1995
when the internet was in its inception
and the uk is a leading country in areas
like digital and data and i think
you've seen from the japan deal that the
uk is prepared to go beyond
what the eu is willing to agree with
in areas like the free flow of data
anti-data localization
which should give a huge strategic
advantages not just to our tech
companies
but also in areas like financial
services and fintech
we've also been able to go further on
mobility
so the ability of professionals and
their families
to travel between the uk and japan we've
gone further in rules of origin
adopting more liberal rules of origin
which will benefit
british business which tends to you know
we are a trading nation we import and we
export so
liberal rules of origin are important to
us we've gone further in protecting our
intellectual property
whether that's for the creative
industries or whether it's for food and
drink
where 70 uh british geographical
indications will now be able to be
recognized whether it's
cornish clotted cream or the stone away
black pudding so
i think this shades the future of
british trade and where we want to go we
we are
a leader in services we're the second
largest services exporter in the world
we can help shape those global rules now
working with like-minded partners
but the final point i make and it really
goes back to what mark was saying about
the economics
he's right and we are conducting a new
study to look at the economics
particularly in areas like digital and
data
that the traditional gravity model which
is based about how far a country is from
another country
doesn't really capture fully but also
trade agreements are important to
protect us from protectionism
because they lock in the benefits of
low tariff barriers low non-tariff
barriers to trade
in a world where even before covert
countries were putting up barriers so it
gives british business security
that they know that they're able to
trade into those markets on those terms
into the long term so it's important
both for the positive benefits
but also for locking in a more free
trade world
and also making that argument on the
global stage the prime minister in his
younger speech
on saturday talked about
lowering tariffs and how the uk global
tariff is setting the example for others
in terms of low tariffs on cavite
critical goods like medical supplies so
i think the uk really has an opportunity
to play a leadership role
in making the case for free trade once
again
great thank you liz um now as i said
please do write any questions you have
into the chat function
and we'll try to get to those and just a
few uh questions picking up on some of
the points
in the opening remarks and adam was
talking about
the census amongst the business
community at least
the you know the eu trade deals still
seen as the biggest one
the most valuable liz i just wondered if
we're looking at
obviously the transition period coming
to an end the idea
of lining up lots of deals ready to go
big progress i made in terms of japan
and have you found that any countries
ultimately want to know the shape
and the details of an eu deal or a lack
of deal
before they can really get over the line
what other countries have wanted to know
is that we're going to have our own
independent regulatory policy and we're
not going to be dynamically aligned to
the eu that's a very important principle
whoever we're negotiating with so given
that's the case given that we've said
that we are going to have sovereignty
over our rules and regulation whether
that's on sanitary and phytosamatry or
whether it's on technical barriers to
trade
that has enabled us to commence and
make real progress in the negotiations
whether it's with
the united states australia or new
zealand
now of course the uh eu trade deal is
important
but we have to remember over time
other parts of the world are going to
become relatively more important
first of all because those are the
places of faster growth and secondly
because as the uk
develops its own independent regulatory
regime we will be able to get
better access to those markets so the eu
has never achieved a trade deal with the
us
but it's also been unwilling to exceed
to the trans-pacific partnership
which is a high standard agreement has
strong areas like digital trade so
over time i think we'll see a shifting
of where the
uk trades with but of course the eu will
continue to be an important trade
partner no one's
no one's denying that adam whether
you're
um looking i suppose at the trade deals
that can potentially have the biggest
impact and clearly the eudl's one we
hear the most about is written about
most in the papers
but what other countries do you think um
sometimes the percentage of gdp can look
uh
fairly minuscule but this is a process
um when you're looking at these but it's
more than that so i wonder
what countries do you think it's
important that you know beyond the eu
we should be focusing on well
of course there are still some
outstanding countries
with whom we've had trade agreements via
our membership of the eu
that are very important to british
business canada is a key example which i
know the secretary of state and her
teams are working on
quite hard right now um you know we've
seen the progress that's been made on
countries like south korea
like japan and others and that's
extremely positive so
there are a few more of those continuity
deals that have an important impact that
we that we would like to see
in terms of other markets i think there
are those where there are big
economic opportunity and there are those
where i think there's some psychological
importance attached to doing
some sort of agreement so if we were to
take australia and new zealand
you know strong friends good trading
partners and very willing business
communities to do more with us
when we talk to the british chamber of
commerce in australia and the british
new zealand business association
desperately keen to see more happening
between the two markets those won't have
the biggest economic impact
of all the deals that could be made but
they do have a psychological impact on
our businesses and draw them out
into more markets on that side of the
world
um there's huge interest of course too
in british business links with the us
they're all already incredibly deep i
suppose the question that we are asked
regularly however is we have these deep
links
on the basis of wto if for whatever the
reason
a huge uh all-encompassing trade
agreement is not
necessarily an easy thing to do for the
reasons of the multi-dimensional chess
that mark was referring to before
what steps can be taken incrementally
and over time
to continue to improve uk companies
trade access to the us and vice versa so
that we can
continue to build on that fantastic
relationship uh
you know whether it's on investment
whether it's on mobility or anything
else
because there are ways of course to
boost trade between markets
without the one gigantic framework
trade agreement you can go incrementally
as well
and mark on that i mean i suppose and
you touch on your opening remarks there
is a tendency in the media sometimes
think of these kind of big blockbuster
moments where everything comes together
so do you think when i mean you've
written previously about
why actually uh not reaching a trade
agreement with the eu would not be the
end of the world there could be some
pros even so what do you think of the
things that we should be seeing in the
next couple of months
six months which will show on the right
track even if you know that that is not
that you know that big photo off of you
know
a world leader and boris johnson or liz
well to to pick up adam's point i mean
you pick the low-hanging fruit first
right so uh i mean it would be
completely
ludicrous if we got into a situation
with the eu
in which there are however long it was
supposed to be the queues were predicted
to be in kent if there's no
deal i mean this becomes absolutely
ridiculous and
you know the my my baseline is to
avoid catastrophic disruption uh even
were that to happen i think that it's
likely that politicians would be forced
around the
table to deal with that and to and to
start to
if you like negotiate a trade deal from
the floor up
rather than the ceiling down with regard
to the eu we're trying to negotiate the
trade deal from the ceiling downwards at
the moment rather than the floor upwards
so i mean i'm not trying to be
phlegmatic about uh even more disruption
after kovid 19 in the
economy uh but at the very least you
want the
you you want the administrative position
with the eu to be
smooth and if there's a very thin deal
or you know some just sort of memorandum
of understanding to make sure that some
stuff can be turned around at dover and
calais then that's something that
needs to be built on and i think there
is a tendency in the media to sort of
say right this is the deadline this is
the date this is the text
there you go that's frozen in f
formaldehyde forever more and that just
won't be the case i'm expecting us
people have been sort of saying oh my
god when will brexit be done when will
we get it over
with and the answer is never because we
will be negotiating our relationship
with the eu
forever more our relationship with the
continent of europe and how we trade
with them is a perennial feature
of our trade policy and our
international
relations and foreign affairs policy
whether we're a member of the
european union or not so i i would say
i agree with adam let's be incremental
about it i
applaud liz's efforts to get
comprehensive trade deals in place if
you can
knock on the head a thousand things at
once in a document hurrah
but if you can't that's not a reason not
to knock one or two things on the head i
mean if we can't agree with the
americans on let's say
agriculture let's at least try and reach
some sort of agreements with them in
mutual recognition professional
qualifications for example
uh so it's just a question of
continually moving the ball
inch by inch closer towards the goal if
you can actually score a spectacular
screamer of a goal from the halfway line
hurrah but if you can't just keep moving
the ball forward
that goes for the eu as well as it does
for the other parts of the world
where we might be able to strike a deal
james and i wondered
mark touch and obviously coronavirus um
in a way we should it feels that you
can't have any conversation about
talking about that at the moment
but do you think coronavirus and clearly
the difficulties in the months ahead in
terms of the restrictions we're
expecting
the fact this would you know this idea
of the v recovery seems to be
slipping further and further out of
sight do you think there's an extra
incentive now both you know on the
government but in terms of
banks the business community to reach
some kind of
agreement with the eu i certainly hope
so katie
um i think um i think that will that
will happen i think to some extent
people are already coming together
around
covid and realizing the impact that's
having not just on national economies
but regional
and global economies um but it was
interesting to listen to some of the
commentary from mark and adam earlier on
and
one of the things i'm very keen on and i
hear from businesses that we talk to
is a clear export strategy um
from the government and i know um that
there was an export strategy which was
published in 2018
and i believe that's being refreshed at
the moment and we've certainly
been talking to department of
international trade who've asked us for
our
input to that but i think having that
clear roadmap
for uk businesses and
identifying what the clear focus areas
are geographies
sectors products and so on as part of
that strategy
along with the support that will be
available for uk businesses
is absolutely critical because that's
really what they need at the moment they
need a degree of
certainty not just for the next two or
three months but for the next
three to five years and adam
one of the things you hear when you when
you speak to figures in government about
the prosper of not having that agreement
at the eu
is the sense that businesses are not
prepared now
i think we can depending on who you
speak to the blame can go either way
some say you know actually the
government guidance is there but lots of
businesses have been very busy
adjusting to coronavirus and there's not
been that uptake others you know blame
moving deadlines
do you think the business community is
in a place
to go for a no deal brexit do you think
there have been adequate preparations
obviously we're hearing about things
like the lovely lorry park
casey certainly business communities
don't want to have that
disorderly scenario at the end of
december and if you look at british
chambers of commerce
research you've got 51 percent of
businesses in a very very timely and
up-to-date survey
saying they do not believe that they are
fully prepared and
they have not been able to make uh the
preparations that are required
now i will put a challenge to government
as the british chambers has done
repeatedly with our brexit uh
checklist we have identified 35 areas
over the course of the last four years
where businesses need
clarity and detail and and really strong
guidance in order to be able to prepare
adequately for change
whether that's a no deal outcome or a
deal outcome you need this baseline
level of clarity
and of those 35 areas you know
preoccupying number
are still rated either red or amber i.e
no information or not enough information
to complete those preparations
so what a lot of businesses are telling
us is they're doing what they can
with the information they have but there
are still some very serious gaps
out there and i think they would take
very badly if at the end of the year the
finger of blame was pointed at them in
some way and say
you didn't use the time that you had
adequately because the response
that you get back from grassroots
businesses is the time that we had
to do what we did not have the clarity
the detail on some of the regulatory
policies for example
on uh some of the the questions around
conformity assessment or any other level
of detail
um you know in time so there's a real
challenge and it's a real joint
enterprise i think over the next three
months for business and government to
try to ensure that that detail is there
business has the clarity it needs and
those that haven't taken those steps
really do use those weeks that are
remaining
we've got a lot of questions coming in
from the us and farming and i want to
want to get to those
but just before we do touching on what
we just heard carla has written in to
ask
what action should businesses be taking
to prepare sounds like that could be the
million dollar question
does anyone on the panel want to have a
go at answering that
otherwise i'll assign oh mark great
you're getting it
i mean i've got a lot of sympathy for
what adam's saying from the business
community side
because of course over any reasonable
time frame you want certainty
and actually in some ways it's easier to
um
run a business knowing that the future
position is going to be
thus and so even if you think thus and
so is a bit mediocre or complex
than having no goddamn idea you know
it's easier to know that whatever the
regulatory framework will be a 4 out of
10
than having no idea at all whether it's
gonna be a one out of ten or
or a nine out of ten so it seems to me
that the
prepare for the worst and hope for the
best is probably the
the appropriate uh position for a
business to take but i
have sympathy with what adam's saying
that the
clearer that the government can give i
mean it can't give certainty this is
uncertain we don't know whether there's
going to be a deal or not there are so
many moving parts i mean there's
the government could not in good
conscience and with honesty say
this is what is going to prevail from
the 1st of january next year they don't
know
and it's not in their gift but i think
that the more the government can do to
give a sort of
tree diagram you know if x we will do y
if z we will do a so
businesses can then chart through
whichever process we're going down and
what would be expected of them
that provides certainty as much as the
government can realistically do so
in a very uncertain world right i'm
going to move on to u.s
and liz this question i think is one for
you it's from dr bogdan sorry if i
mispronounce
anyone's names and how far are we from
concluding a deal of the us
now we're about to go we are in a u.s
election so that doesn't complicate
things quite a lot so
where are we at yeah so a lot of
countries where trading would seem to
have a habit of having elections
uh the new zealanders are also having an
election which has
uh compromised our
negotiation schedule we will we will
progress anyway
so i think it's worth just addressing
what mark said earlier
about trade agreements under wta rules
the vast majority of trade has to be
covered in any free trade agreement
so it's not the case you can just pick
off
a small element of trade and come come
to an agreement on that because of the
most favored nation tariff rules you do
have to make sure the vast majority is
covered in any agreement you reach
and in each of the negotiations we're
having
each country has its offensive interests
so
no country is going to do a deal just on
the basis of the other country's
offensive interests and not go
get what they want so inherently these
deals have to have
a certain amount of comprehensiveness in
them so it's not just because
politicians want to get a great headline
mark
it's also because of the wta rules and
the nature of the trade-offs in the
agreement
that you have to achieve a certain
amount but of course there are
differences
between the shallow sort of agreement
and a deeper agreement
so you know i would argue the japan
agreement we've struck
is deeper than the one the eu struck
uh because it covers areas like data and
digital and much more depth so
there are varying degrees of depth but i
think each agreement has to be
a basic fta level in order to pass
muster
uh on the wta rules and as you rightly
say
all of these deals are constructed from
the floor up and that's what's very
different between the negotiations i'm
doing at the department of international
trade
and the eu negotiation which is starting
from
the top down and so where we are with
the us
is we've pretty much laid all the text
on both sides
we're now in a position of consolidating
those texts so if you like that's
laying the foundations for the deal
debating the various chapters and where
exactly we get to on those
at the same time as discussing the
tariff reductions that we want
on key areas of goods so
we are in the middle if you like of
creating that foundation
for a successful deal now of course
we'd like to make as much progress as we
can in advance of the us election and
because of the way the u.s system works
they can carry on negotiating pretty
much right up to that
so that we can try and realize the
benefits as quickly as possible
also the u.s trade promotion authority
which allows an up-down vote on a deal
in congress expires mid-next year so
that is
an important point for us to try and
reach an agreement by
i'm always very clear on all of these
deals that
we will not strike a deal that doesn't
work for the uk regardless of what the
deadline is
because as adam pointed out we've
already got a good trading relationship
with the us we're only going to do a
deal with the us if it
improves on that trading relationship
and it gives us more of what
of what the uk wants so in respect of
farm
standards which was the question you
asked katie
you know we've imported all of the
current eu law and farm standards so
the ban on chlorinated chicken the ban
on hormone
injected beef you know those remain
of course over time we will have the
uk's
own regulatory framework for agriculture
you know we're leaving the common
agricultural policy we're developing our
own policy which is more focused on the
environment
i mean we are a country that cares
deeply about animal welfare
so those are the types of policies that
we will
be developing over time but it will be a
gradual evolution
you know the world is not going to
change in terms of farm regulations on
the 1st of january 2021
and what we have to do with the united
states and also with
all the other partners we're negotiating
with is
come to an arrangement where we have
um an agreement that reflects our
priorities
whilst enabling access
for our producers to other markets and
them
to us and of course that goes into huge
amounts of detail
but what we have is we have people
representing the farming industry
closely involved in advising us on the
negotiations so we know
what every line we agree whatever tariff
change we agree
it will work for british industry and
consumers
but it's a it's of course a vastly
complex area to go into
but we've been very clear in our
manifesto we're not going to undermine
the very high standards we have in
britain in any of those agreements and
i think it's perfectly doable to get a
successful deal with the us
that takes that into account and
likewise to exceed
to the trans-pacific partnership which
is
another strategic priority
so in terms of deadline we're looking at
the middle of next year as a potential
uh important one for each so mark has
warned me against deadlines now
i want to talk about farming standards a
little bit more but first i wouldn't use
that as a deadline because
the point is we will not do a bad deal
just to hit a deadline
i do think deadlines can be helpful in
focusing minds
so with respect to japan you know we
needed to do it
a certain amount of time in advance in
order to
go through the process in the uk
parliament and also the japanese diet
and that was useful for focusing minds
in getting a win-win deal for bethesda
and japan and that is the approach we'll
use but of course
if the other party is unreasonable we're
not just going to say fine we'll sign
up to your terms a potential date of
interest for people's diaries who follow
trade policy we'll get we're going to
call that
and now mark just i wanted to stay on
feed standards ellen has asked
what is mark's position on dropping food
standards and trade deals
especially with the us now often we hear
about
chlorinated chicken there's also other
ways you can obviously
have competing food standards
potentially cheaper options on the
market shelves so can you
talk us through where you stand on this
yeah i mean in my view it should be
based on the science i'm not a scientist
my limited understanding of the science
is that hormone-injected beef and
chlorinated chicken
don't pose a risk to life in limb i have
never met or come across
or heard of any british person visiting
the united states
and refusing to eat chicken or beef
there on the grounds that it is
chlorinated or hormone injected not one
i mean you might refuse to eat chicken
or beef on the grounds that you're a
vegetarian but that would apply
uh either way round so my broad approach
to it based on the science by
all means i mean i'm open to persuasion
that
you know if we let in this particular
food product from this particular
country it has risks of i don't know
salmonella or whatever anything else um
that is one consideration i'm
i'm less moved myself by animal welfare
standards to be honest
um but i appreciate that's a government
policy and and then
what i would say which sounds a bit
trivial basically label things properly
um as long as the consumer is
aware of what they're purchasing i would
like to maximize consumer
choice i quite like american chicken and
american beef
and i'd like to be able to buy them in
tesco's
not just in las vegas when i go on
holiday so the science should guide it
choice should guide it um and
um the last thing i would say that which
where liz is right
uh completely right is that too often
there's a massive focus on agriculture
which is actually a relatively small
part of gdp
if we can't agree on chicken and beef
i'll be
disappointed but it's not exactly the
end of our deal
our trade with america is not chicken
and beef focused particularly
far more important to get more technical
things over the line about public
procurement policies
alignment and financial services and the
rest of it but
my view is have the science maximize
consumer choice
and ask yourself is this really a
problem we're facing
or is this cloaked up protectionism to
defend the
interests of the british producer rather
than the british consumer
yeah liz just on there then i want to go
to the rest of the panel i mean just
this weekend you had jamie oliver
and joe wicks joining the cries you know
urging the government
not to open their floodgates to
low-quality food imports
and now low-quality clearly conscious of
many views and
it can often feel as though we spend the
hold of this debate talking about
chlorinated chicken and
woman-injected beef but it's also the
case i think during the eu referendum
and
since since forest johnson's win there
are plenty of tory mps who
particularly and i think blue barricade
red wall constituencies whatever you
want to want to call them
and do you see a tangible benefit of
leaving the eu
for their constituents as having cheaper
food options
on the supermarket shelf so do you think
that we are going to see that come
through in a potential uk us trade deal
so first of all i think there's a huge
opportunity
for british producers globally
i was in david's day last week looking
at their cheddar exports they're now
exporting to the us and canadian market
and even though the us have a 25
tariff the cheese is still competitive
because it's such high quality
and that is the future of british
produce
it's high quality high wealth their
goods
which are in demand across the world so
i think
part of my argument would be
that we should be more positive about
what we have to offer the world
it it's often looked as a one-way trade
but we've been very successful we're now
a net exporter of dairy products for the
first time in years because our farmers
are doing
a great job and because there is demand
for high quality british products across
the world of course we're not going to
compete with brazil
for producing that volume but in terms
of quality i think british farming is
unbeatable and
we should be proud of that there's also
a misnomer
that products in the u.s are cheaper in
fact the price of beef in the us is
pretty much what the price of beef in
the eu is
so i think there's a idea that
there'll be floods of products is not is
not true
i think the genuine point that a lot of
farmers have expressed to me
they would consider it unfair if
practices that are banned in the uk
because of animal welfare reasons that
are allowed elsewhere
if those products were allowed to come
in and undercut
the standards that our farmers are asked
to follow then that becomes difficult
and i
i agree with that which is why in any
trade deal we negotiate we will be
taking that into account because
we don't want to undermine the standards
we're asking
our farmers to follow so i think that's
an important principle
but that doesn't mean that we can't
trade with the united states
that we can't trade with australia new
zealand and other countries and in fact
there are already equators for high
quality
us beef into the eu
there are other products that we import
and what trade deals are all about is
trying to work
out where the opportunities are
and i think now we've left the eu we
don't have to have
the high tariff wall we don't have to
have the protectionist
common agricultural policy we can be
more open but in a way that suits
british interests and also the british
perspective on these issues so
that is something to me that is
perfectly possible to navigate but what
isn't helpful is just scare
stories about chlorinated chicken and
hormone beef when it's already banned
in the uk anyway and i think there is a
fair amount of sort of
bandwagon jumping if i could put it like
that that doesn't reflect
the negotiations we're actually having
are you gonna give joe wicks a call then
and
uh share some truth bullets
i'm very happy to katy and
adam i just want to bring you in at this
point um that i want to talk about other
countries and trade deals because we
spend a lot of time in the u.s but
i just want to particularly us because
clearly it sounds so you know
few people expect anything before the
election
very material do you think that there is
a sense in the
business community and generally um you
know at the commerce that
there has been a slow uh
a slow path to getting these trade deals
signed up or do you think everyone
thinks this is kind of the schedule
anyway
is there gonna be disappointment that
some of these things don't come sooner
well invariably casey in business when
people want to do something they want to
do it yesterday and anyone who is sat
where liz is right now is always under
that pressure
as fast as possible um and and
businesses do want to see
as as many of these framework agreements
and trade agreements as possible
materialize within a short
time frame so to the discussion
previously we can get to some of the
certainty
that they bring and and the
opportunities that they bring
um i suppose okay there was one thing i
wanted to add
to a point that was made a little bit
earlier i don't want to drive the debate
back to agriculture because that's not
where i actually am on this
but i do think the british media and
political lens focuses on
one small area of many trade
negotiations
to the detriment of all of the others
that are out there
so i'm sitting here representing
businesses who say to me
getting stuff through customs processes
in the us
is what adds a huge amount of paperwork
and time to my business
i'm an sme you know some countries have
preferential arrangements for smes to
trade with each other with lighter rules
when can we get something like that or
on mobility moving people between
offices in different countries which
matters to them
or as mark mentioned getting into
procurement and being able to go into a
market like the us and not face
very high domestic barriers to
participating in
procurements there all of this b2b stuff
rather than the consumer-facing stuff
is a big part of what is going to make
us rich through trading more with
other countries it needs a much better
airing and more visibility out there
over the months ahead so colleagues in
the media could do all of us a great
service by talking about
the slightly less sexy bits of trade
negotiations and trade agreements
because they really do matter
to the national bottom line okay james
i'll bear that in mind when i next have
to write something
um no sorry james the question i had for
you
thank you adam is ultimately we have a
question in just about free trade more
generally and i know you were saying in
your remarks
earlier uh you know supportively of it
and
natalie has asked does complete free
trade actually work in the modern world
aren't the various strands of trade too
wide-ranging and
i think you can probably bring into that
coronavirus in a way
appears to be been or at least encourage
arguments of self-sufficiency
of in some cases protectionism if you
look at how
uh we've seen the problems of supply
chains on things like ppe
and so you see some countries moving
away from that so do you think the
case for free trade has been made more
difficult over the past few months and
james um yes i think that has i mean
certainly if you're adam smith
and you definitely think that free trade
globally is the right way forwards
um but frankly the reality is that
free trade globally is unlikely because
there are so many different viewpoints
out there
some different interests out there and
all of that has been complicated
by some of the issues that i referenced
earlier on so covid
trade tensions et cetera and to some
extent
rise of nationalism and local production
and so on
but i do think we need to continue to
move towards free trade because i do
think it's beneficial for businesses and
people
uh globally so we should always be
moving towards that
maxim even though we may never
ultimately get there
um and making that progress in that
regard
one point i just wanted to make earlier
on and add to what adam was saying about
um customs and cross-border facilitation
in terms of
border friction and i think this is a
valid point is
technology is now starting to pay or
play a big role in
the movement of goods and trade finance
in general
over the last three years or so we've
really seen
a significant increase in the move
towards digitization blockchain
solutions
supply chain finance platforms and so on
and covid is really
turbocharging that whole move at the
moment with everything that's happened
and one of the challenges to achieving
that
nirvana if you like is different
technical standards different legal
standards
different regulations across different
countries and regions
governing the acceptance of electronic
documentation
there are some countries like singapore
now which are very focused on trying to
be a hub
which really starts to try and encourage
standardization across regions and
across
trade corridors and i think the uk could
play a very important role in that going
forwards to help
facilitate the digitization of trade to
help facilitate the movement of goods
and services across
borders and reduce border friction thank
you
now um when we're talking about big
economies countries that
clearly could make a big impact in terms
of our
economy on growing it china can't really
be avoided but at the same time it does
feel as though the government has taken
uh i've been corrected in the past and i
said hostile
but i think depending on which tory mp
you speak to it definitely feels at
least in the
parliamentary conservative party you
have a
block arranging across various factions
who want a tougher approach with china
and we've seen parts of that
uh in various things like huawei some
disquiet over tick tock
and mark what do you think the uk's
approach to trade with china should be
and it goes a long way now from the
golden era that we heard about when
george osborne and david cameron were in
charge
and but yet we cannot deny obviously
the the global superpower anyway that
china is so what should we do
well i i think this is more of a sort of
question of geopolitics than directly of
trade
um there are enormous problems with
china when liz gets to sitting down with
a chinese counterparts the the scale of
the problems that she faces are
considerably greater than
talking to her aussie american or kiwi
counterparts i mean how can you sign a
trade deal
with a country that has such an
outrageous record on defending
intellectual property for example uh i
mean
you're you know you're almost in the
courts before you start
so uh i would you know i would like us
to have a
peaceful meaningful and trading
relationship relationship with china
but you're not really just starting the
floor there and building up you're
somewhere deep in the cellar
and building up right i mean you haven't
really even got the foundations in place
so i see that as high high hanging fruit
i mean the sensible thing to do uh you
know
is to get the deals over the line which
are the easiest to achieve
broadly speaking the democratic world to
some degree the english-speaking world
i would probably have more focus and
more optimism about india
um than china in terms of getting a deal
over the line i think the wider
commonwealth should be a target
so i'm not a cynophobe but i but i think
that there is a geopolitical question
here which isn't just about the
easing of trade and that we start from a
pretty bleak position
in that it is difficult to patrol what's
actually happening
to for example british or american iep
when it enters the chinese market so
that is the longest hardest
highest hanging fruit and to get to any
kind of free trade deal with china is
going to take many many years of pushing
water uphill
james what do you think to that in terms
of how as a country
should be approaching china and because
as i was saying there was a point when
it was encouraged
and there are various businesses that
went to strengthen ties and now it feels
like it's been a very
sharp shift i mean from our perspective
we will obviously follow the direction
that our clients
or customers who are uk businesses ask
us to try and help them follow
um and if that's china then we'll help
them with china to the extent that we
can if it's
the us then we'll do the same so i don't
think it's really my place to discuss
or opine on um how we negotiate with
with china but i would say that
absolutely we're here to help
business uk businesses deal with
countries like china as indeed the us
and other other countries
liz do you think china is a country that
you expect to be doing much business
with in terms looking at trade
agreements
um neil o'brien uh mp in your own party
who uh what is what holds a position on
the china research group
has said that ultimately the problem is
it's not really a
country that self practices free trade
so therefore
if you look at how you know it can fund
itself the various wings that people say
are not so much businesses but brings
the chinese government it's hard to do
that
so do you think it is there is something
to be done there well certainly the case
at the
world trade organization that
uh alliance of the us japan the eu and
also the uk
are challenging china's practices so in
areas like
force technology transfer uh subsidy
subsidization by state-owned industry of
products
uh the ip issues that mark was talking
about
and i i think there are serious issues
of the world trade organization in terms
of the
operation and countries following the
rules
which are need to be fixed obviously
we've got liam fox as our candidate at
the moment
uh pushing pushing that that argument
but the wto is in
serious need of reform and my view is
the way the uk should work
is work with like-minded allies to
create structures
that fundamentally challenge the way the
wto is operating
and force it to reform and the the
primary vehicle for that
is the trans-pacific partnership it's a
high standards agreement where countries
in it follow the rules
it operates in areas like data and
digital that the wto do not have
advanced rules in as well as the united
kingdom there are a number of other
countries seeking to exceed
uh to tpp like thailand so i see that as
a growing group
of like-minded countries who can
challenge the way that the wto
operates i also agree with mark about
india i think india is a very strong
prospect
for the next phase of our trade
agreements we've had a very good jet co
with the indians recently we've got
another one this autumn
to prepare the ground but of course
india is a major world democracy
and working with like-minded democracies
to shape
the global rules i think is very
important great now
because we only have a couple of minutes
left and i've been told i have to end on
time i thought we could end by just
going around the panel and
within 30 seconds to one minute and
say what you think is the most important
thing the uk could do
right now we know in the coming months
to reclaim free trade
um who would like to go first mark do
you want to go first
yeah give liz trust more power and more
staff probably is the most important
thing we can probably do to
facilitate free trade we are never ever
going to get it
we're never going to get complete global
free trade of course
we're never going to get a complete
level playing field there will always be
people complaining about unfair
competition i was just looking up
the minimum wage in the uk is eight
pounds twenty one the federal minimum
wage in america is five pounds sixty
so there's always going to be uh you
know a lack of a level playing field
but we need to act according to the
principles articulated by liz and the
prime minister
even if we're not going to get total
global free trade
uh world free trade is like is like
looking up at the stars you're not
ever going to reach them but you benefit
enormously from their presence
and adam the biggest thing we can do to
reclaim free trade over the coming
months is remember trade isn't just
about
policy it's also about promotion we have
fantastic
companies in this country james's point
before about having a strong
export strategy and being able to help
all of those companies get out there in
the world
regardless of whether they're operating
under a trade agreement
or not is absolutely critical we also
need to spend
more as a country on the promotion of
our trade
the budgets that we have to do this big
mission
is very very small at the moment we
don't want to spend on wisely or throw
money away of course but i do think we
need to invest
in it if we're really going to make it
happen james you get the penultimate
word
thank you katie um for me part of this
is about thought leadership and it's
about projecting
the uk britain as a real thought leader
in terms of
trade free trade export strategies and
so on going forwards
that will help us develop the right
partnerships uh inspire the right
confidence and hopefully
influence others to do as we want to i'm
sure we're doing all of that
i mentioned earlier the technology and
digital and data elements i think that's
important and that falls into that
thought leadership element
and earlier on in my presentation i
mentioned the importance of uk export
finance and the department of
international trade
and other departments like it to
continue to invest in those
um in my view those at those departments
are absolutely vital
in working with uk businesses and with
banks such as ourselves to help
facilitate
our you know our clients and uk
businesses trade
and liz you get the final 30 seconds
before i have to cut everyone off
well first of all i'm very grateful to
everybody's support for dit
spending review bid thank you very much
we'll be using that in our
evidence to the to the treasury
i think it's very important we make the
case because there are always going to
be naysayers are always going to be
doubters there are always going to be
protectionists
it's an easy knee-jerk argument to make
so what we need is
businesses thinkers to actually be out
there on the front foot
challenging some of the misinformation
that gets spread on the media about
trade because
we're doing trade deals because it
benefits businesses and consumers here
in the uk
and it's part of our future prosperity
and then the final point i'd make is we
do have friends around the world
you know we do have like-minded allies
that believe the same thing we've got
great countries like australia and new
zealand who have
led in free trade i see it as we are
coming to join them
uh and work with them so let's not just
think it's us making that argument there
is a broader group of countries
japan included as well who also want to
make the case with us
brilliant thank you liz and thank you to
the rest of our panel it's been a really
interesting discussion
and thank you to barclays for sponsoring
today's discussion